this means the Oneness of God now this
other thing that I'm going to show the
reporter
this one here yes hold on a second guys
so guys the Western media cannot help
themselves they are trying and looking
for ways how they can dehumanize and
vilify Muslims oh one German reporter
reporter actually found a nice way of
trying to connect this symbol to
Isis Isis here's what you have to say
and I am going to be giving him a finger
also very soon let's just first watch
that inshallah
is
so as you guys saw for yourself who in
their right mind would think this just
because a group of people used this it
means that now anybody that used this
symbol it means they are evil or bad no
they know very well he's not stupid he
knows very well I think he might be
stupid actually yeah but he knows very
well that this has no connection to that
but no they had to make the connection
because it's the first time Morocco a
Muslim a a African country North African
country is going to the finals and
they're like this is impossible we are
we are supposed to be the best at
everything you know The White Man's
Burden of you know we're coming to save
you we are here to show you the best way
of life and you need to follow us and
when they see Morocco do that it's
impossible how how can we connect it to
something evil and let the people
remember the Moroccans as something evil
this means the Oneness of God now this
other thing that I'm going to show the
reporter this one here yes hold on a
second guys why is everyone well whoa
whoa you calm down
this is a social construct this social
this is this is a finger it's a social
construct in China this doesn't mean
what it means actually right even a
Russian athlete who once won the
Olympics from the mistaken he did the
same put two middle fingers up yeah so
this can mean excuse me in different
things and obviously in the UK in
different parts of the world this is an
insult it's an offensive insult but
however in different parts of the world
it means something totally different
yeah I mean this in Italy is rude but
you know in my country or someone so it
means you know I want to eat food you
know can I have something to eat so
different things work in different ways
so to the German reporter like this here
if you can see this here this this can
mean something else now you're speaking
German Hit List Hitler spoke German he
might have used the very same words that
you uttered yes he may have said the
same things now does this mean that now
somehow I'm going to come and say oh
this reporter used very same phrases
same words that Hitler used would you
not think that I have even intentions
yes so anyways that's all I had to say
brother and sisters it just show you
shows you guys how desperate they are
that the Muslim World Qatar is doing an
amazing job and the fans on the ground
are exposing the media lives because
they are having one amazing time I mean
I came across one guy who discovered uh
you know washing your backside with
water and his whole life changed yes I
mean just Buddha and you know he said
why have we been using tissue all this
time so there's many things that you
will learn from Muslim World especially
when it comes to morality which you have
no moral compass and you're all over the
place it's something you should turn to
and maybe read the Quran till next time
for me to our German reporter
goodbye